130 тисяч євро - приблизно в таку суму
обходиться німецьким батькам утримання однієї дитини
до досягнення нею 18-річчя, підрахувало
Федеральне статистичне відомство.
Тут враховані витрати на їжу, одяг, транспорт, додаткові заняття, кишенькові гроші.
Однак у кожній родині виникає ситуація, що вимагає від батьків
додаткових фінансових витрат.
Це може бути поїздка з класом за кордон, рік навчання за кордоном
або отримання водійських прав.
Тож, серед німців важко знайти батьків,
які не намагалися б подбати про стартовий капітал для свого чада.
Гроші в подарунок дитині -  в Німеччині це не рідкість.
Коли накопичується пристойна сума, яка вже не поміщається
в дитячу скарбничку,  гроші, як правило, несуть до банку.
Перевага віддається звичайному ощадному рахунку.
Єдина проблема при такому капіталовкладенні - низькі відсоткові ставки.
Аби гроші "запрацювали", іноді на ім'я дитини відкривають спеціальний депозит.
Чим довше гроші зберігаються в банку,
тим вища відсоткова ставка, і відповідно - прибуток.
Але головна мета, яку переслідують батьки - не прибутковість,
а збереження дитячих грошей, щоб дитина
не розтринькала свої накопичення на якісь дрібниці.
Серед тих, хто хоче зібрати до 18-річчя дитини
пристойну суму, але так, щоб це не було відчутно для сімейного бюджету,
досить популярний так званий дитячий накопичувальний план - Kindersparplan,
який пропонують німецькі банки.
Батьки регулярно - зазвичай раз на місяць -
протягом визначеного договором терміну
перераховують на спеціальний банківський рахунок певну суму -
від 25 євро і вище - під невеликий, але гарантований відсоток.
Такий спосіб економії добрий тим, що, не залазячи в борги,
в майбутньому можна профінансувати освіту дитини, приміром,
рік шкільного обміну за кордоном, оренду житла для студента
і, можливо, навіть купівлю моторолера або недорогого автомобіля.
У Німеччині на кожну дитину держава виплачує Kindergeld -
дослівно "дитячі гроші".
Нині це по 194 євро на місяць на першу та другу дитину,
200 на третю і 225 євро на четверту і більше дітей.
Якщо родина може дозволити собі заощаджувати ці гроші від народження дитини,
це дозволяє зібрати до повноліття вельми пристойну суму -
понад 40 тисяч євро. А якщо протягом цього періоду
ще інші родичі поповнюватимуть рахунок -
приміром, з нагоди дня народження або Різдва,
то сума буде ще більшою.
Багато батьків у Німеччині прагнуть навчити дитину
ощадливості з дитинства. Одна з можливостей -
відкриття спеціального "дитячого" рахунку в банку - Kinderkonto.
Вони регулярно перераховують на нього кишенькові гроші,
а потім разом з дитиною рахують, як і на що їх витрачати.
Діти у Німеччині не сприймають як норму, що батьки
мають платити за їхнє навчання, отримання водійських прав,
не кажучи вже про купівлю автомобіля або квартири.